well desmond can speak to himself speak
for himself he joins me now live thank
you very much indeed for being with mr
desmond
i just want to ask you first of all
whether you regret those two interviews
which you gave
to save our rights uk and to adele big
tree
i certainly regret the fuss that they've
caused in being at the center of a media
storm
when i would much rather the focus of
today's news being on
astrazeneca and it's back with the
european union
do you accept that you you were wrong uh
in what you said
back in november to save our rights uk
it seems to be a manageable risk
particularly as the figures have been
manipulated
we're told there's a deathly deadly
pandemic proceeding at the moment
that is difficult to reconcile with
intensive care units actually operating
at typical occupation levels
for the time of year and us bouncing
around at the typical level of deaths
for the time of year
i mean you were wrong weren't you as it
turned out
no i think at the time at the time those
were that that was a legitimate point of
view
i accept entirely that the situation has
changed and changed dramatically as a
consequence of the new variant
but i think those were perfectly
legitimate and widely held views
uh uh at the time
yeah but but they were wrong weren't
they i mean even at the time
i think excess deaths were up 14
uh on uh normal according to all the
official statistics and of course now
they're much higher than that and
whether you go by covert related deaths
uh or indeed uh excess deaths we're well
over a hundred thousand now aren't we so
so you know
you were wrong then and you and you
accept that now do you
with hindsight
no no all these statistics can be
presented in a number of ways
i i and seen in the round the reality is
that we've had four years
in the last five that make up the five
year average uh of relatively
uh benign performance certainly with flu
being
suppressed and therefore being within 15
of the five-year average is not
untypical
if you look uh over the last over the
last
decade or so you will see that years
bought up and down to very significant
extents
hang on wait a minute i mean we're now
above 15
uh are you not accepting that excess
deaths due to covid
are above 100 000 are you are you saying
that that is
inaccurate no no i'm not saying that i'm
saying that
i'm saying what i have said in the house
of commons
i have complained about the way that
statistics have been presented
and information and data has has been
revealed
i i've said that on the record in the
house of commons
no different to know what i've said okay
but but if you if if you accept that
they're more than 100 000 excess deaths
what are you complaining about i mean
that
that that's a fact isn't it and to
question that or to talk about hidden
agendas
that is fake news isn't it no i
i complained about the way that data has
been presented
as i have in the house of commons on the
record yeah but what is your complaint
what is your complaint
about how is it wrong for us to be given
these statistics by
the office of national statistics and
other sources ones which
reputable people like ed conway and
chris giles and
the financial times all have verified
what what is wrong about the way it's
being presented i've already answered
your question even if you didn't like
the answer
these questions these this data is
presented
in a particular way we've seen various
aspects of the way the data was
presented
by government to parliament which has
unwound in the days
afterwards and had to be represented
it's
perfectly legitimate are you having
trouble just haven't produced any
you haven't produced any evidence for
that you're making an assertion
which is undermining people's perception
of the scale of the problem
and you're not telling me you're saying
you're complaining about it but you're
not giving me any evidence of what of
what's been done wrong in your views
let's take the the example to which i
was thinking about
uh at the time uh which was uh if i
remember
in the early autumn when the two chiefs
chief scientist and chief medical
officer
presented uh their scenario
and within a couple of days after work
by professor
hennigan and by the spectator magazine
that
unwound and had to be represented and i
raised that in parliament i have
complained
about the way that statistics absolutely
said the problem the problem is the
problem is that professor hennigan
and his predictions are now totally
discredited
uh and he's gone rather silent and
indeed the spectator that was
championing that
events the deaths the real people dying
the real people getting long covered
have disproved your claims that these
statistics were being misrepresented
and therefore that's why michael gove is
asking you to apologize are you prepared
to apologize
my comments were perfectly legitimate
at the time and that's the point
what may have changed subsequently is
is immaterial you're asking me to to
comment
on things that were said in november
which were perfectly legitimate then
yes things have changed that's that's
question that's questionable but you
accept things have changed
so with hindsight go back to my earlier
question
do you now regret giving those
interviews and will you apologize for
them as michael gove has asked
no the complaint was legitimate at the
time the way that statistics were being
presented
even if subsequently deaths have
ballooned
and they have at the time those comments
were perfectly legitimate
the chief whip has asked you to meet
with scientific advisors
presumably he's thinking of people like
jonathan van turm and chris whittie
and valance have you met with them are
you prepared to meet with them
absolutely i'll meet with anyone
yes but are you prepared to meet with
those people and to accept
the briefings that they give you
absolutely
and are there are there any plans now
for that to take place imminently
uh not the time not that i'm yet aware
of
and uh do you fear that you might be
suspended from the conservative party
because there's also been criticism
from the party hierarchy for your
comments well that would be thought
crime
but i mean have you been told that you
are in danger of
suspension if you don't i have not i
have not
okay now i want to ask you about
vaccinations because as you know the the
two people we showed you being
interviewed with in that report louise
canfield and del victory are both
campaigners against
vaccines would you uh when the
opportunity arises will you have
personally a coveted vaccine
yes absolutely i'm evangelical
in my support for vaccination that was
clear from the question that i put to
the prime minister yesterday
even the most cursory examination of the
blogs on my website will see
my enthusiasm for the vaccination
program
again things that i've said in
parliament
and so again do you then regret the fact
that you
by appearing and we saw uh dell big tree
talking about how honored he was to
speak to you and the rest
do you regret that you helped
you know actually give credibility to
those organizations which you spoke to
i don't believe i have given credibility
i spoke to them
on the issue of the lockdown i didn't we
never we
never touched on the issue of
vaccination
i had no idea that dell big tree who i'd
never heard of before
had any uh previous on
vaccination so the reality is i stuck to
the
the the brief that i was given i was
asked about lockdown
and i talked about lockdown
what do you say to people who are now
going into hospitals and
protesting and saying that patients
should be released and that there's no
such thing as covid
i think they're nutty
nutty nutty yes
it's clear that there is covid it's
clear that we're we have a major health
problem
uh but i dispute the the the chosen
policies that we've
dealt with it's perfectly legitimate
there's nothing that i have said
in these encounters that i'm not on the
record as having said
in parliament okay
would you do an interview again with uh
dale big tree or save our
our rights uk uh i would be rather
cautious about that
and uh just finally um yesterday uh the
announcements from the prime minister
amount to an extension of this third
lockdown
into march do you support that in the
present circumstances
no i've been against lockdown from the
start but i did think we've made
significant progress yesterday with the
uh prime minister announcing that he
would be producing the plan
and what i thought was particularly
helpful from the prime minister
yesterday
was he assured me that there would be no
mission creep
beyond the need to reduce hospital
admissions that the key
metric here is progress in vaccination
particularly with the vulnerable groups
who would likely to be hospitalized
if they were to become infected that is
the key to ending the lockdown
what about wearing masks in public
places do you support that
i've never supported that i made that
clear from
absolutely the first i believe
government did it for the best of
possible motives
but i disagree with it i voted against
it
but hey it's a democracy i was on the
losing side
and so i wear my mask as required
i said desmond um you know you're a
public servant you've been a minister no
one will question your integrity but it
does seem
that your message to the public is going
against the very traditional one of uh
better safe than sorry
well the fact is we are
sorry the reality is that we've been in
some form of lockdown in three
iterations
uh throughout almost the last year and
still we have a hundred thousand deaths
and we have done enormous damage
to our children's education
and to the economy
so it's perfectly legitimate for me as a
politician
to make a counter argument to have said
that actually i think there were
different things different
policy options that we should have
pursued and to even if
i speak for a minority do we still
believe in freedom of expression in this
country or not
i mean you've raised i being suspended
for saying these things
well that's up to your party but we're
very happy to hear your views but i i do
want to put it to you that
had you been listened to most scientific
analysis
would be that many many more people
would have died
or had this uh serious disease as a
result and
uh therefore you know many people might
think you might regret some of your past
comments
well that's a that is a perfectly
legitimate debate to have but
equally there are you know there are
literally
scores of thousands who have uh
including clinicians and scientists who
signed the great barrington
declaration you know it's an argument a
legitimate argument to be had
well it was the argument about sweden
for example but we know sweden now has
had
very bad outcomes so i mean i'm just
puzzled by
if you like uh your refusal to benefit
from hindsight
well i i i've just i've just raised
hindsight to you
we have had we have had lockdowns
and we've had a hundred thousand deaths
and we've had huge damage to our economy
in the life chances
of young people and our children's
education that strikes me as perfectly
legitimate to say
was there another way of having gone
about this
okay so just on that point of michael
goves he's asked you to apologize for
your past comments
are you prepared to do that i have a
great deal of respect for michael gove i
uh on on occasion i backed him for the
leadership
and i have worked with him closely in
the camera administration
and i will always reflect on his
comments
but i'm not clear as to what i'm being
asked to apologize
for uh and i just wonder
if he has fallen for that sky news
headline
senior tory tells anti-vaxxers
to carry on and indicates his support
which is a monstrous distortion
of the truth so desmond swain thank you
very much indeed for joining us